officials from the oakland a's are in
town tonight looking at possible
locations
for a ballpark ron futrell joining us
now with a look at some of the possible
locations
for the a's here in las vegas
yeah brian we've got a lot of empty
spaces here in the valley where a
ballpark could work 30 acres would be
a tight fit 60 acres would be plenty of
room for a ballpark and plenty of
parking for locals
and that's important by the way we'll
show you a few general spots
that are being looked at first of all
let's take a look at oh in north las
vegas
up there across from the speedway at
i-15 a lot of blm land up there we'll
talk more about that in a moment also
near the va hospital
is another possible site to look at way
in the south part of the valley all the
way
out near the end casino a lot of land
out there
where they could possibly find a place
to be able to put a ballpark
by the thomas and mack center near the
airport is another location
that we understand the a's are looking
at paradise and tropicana
and then finally the rock and rio site
okay this is a sahara
and las vegas boulevard south right
across from the sahara hotel
another spot that they are looking at we
understand right now but that north las
vegas location
a couple of locations out there mayor
john lee would like to make that happen
fifty percent of north las vegas has
been built out yet we have a lot of land
i've got a piece of property 450 acres
right now
that has worked a development zone that
we could put together a cross street can
be a
va hospital i have 135 acres
we could take that big 450 we could put
the stadium on it
we could put the practice fields on it
and we could put the executive offices
on it
one-stop shop for the a's yeah well the
a's and las vegas have a great
relationship
they played regular season games and
exhibition games here in town the
aviators of course are the
aaa affiliate for the oakland a so they
certainly like las vegas a's management
they're in town
making at least their fourth trip to las
vegas today and tomorrow talking about
how to make this work if it can there
are a lot of moving parts
finding the right location is just one
part of it